34 days after the horrific events at the
astroworld festival travis scott is
facing new questions welcome to
entertainment tonight everybody yeah
that tragedy left 10 people dead and
hundreds injured now travis is telling
his side of the story to tv and radio
host charlemagne the god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
emotional roller coaster you know it
hurts it's just been a lot of thoughts
you know a lot of feelings a lot of
grieving when did you find out things
got as bad as they did it wasn't really
until like minutes until like the press
conference until i figured out exactly
what happened so you didn't know people
that actually passed away and stuff no
wow
it's an ambulance
during the hour-long sit sit-down travis
explained why he kept playing for nearly
40 minutes after police declared the
concert a mass casualty incident and
fans were heard screaming for the show
to stop
you hear any of those screams nah man
and you know
it's so crazy because i'm not i'm that
artist too like you know anytime you can
hear something like that you want to
stop the show you know i got
music i got my in-ears but i just didn't
i just didn't hear that you know
so far about 275 lawsuits have been
filed asking for damages of about three
billion dollars the 30-year-old rapper
and kylie jenner's baby daddy filed to
be dismissed from 11 of them and in
documents scott and his company quote
generally deny the allegations it isn't
necessarily a cut and dry case likely
this will be in the court system four
years legal expert rachel stockman
weighs in on the interview so far
reaction has been mixed some sympathetic
to travis others thinking the sit-down
was a bad idea attorneys on these cases
are taking this interview trying to
figure out if there's anything they can
use from that interview against travis
clearly what his defense is going to be
is i wasn't in charge of all of the
safety measures who does travis scott
ultimately think is responsible
i don't want to just speak too soon i
just want to figure out you know what
happened as artists we just leave this
up to professionals to make sure people
are protected and can you know leave and
have the
best experience ever
now travis also said he wants to step up
to make sure nothing like this happens
in the future great interview by
charlemagne 60 minutes you watching